getting out while they still can
these passengers are on the last flights
out of kathmandu as nepal suspends
international air travel
i'm glad that i'm able to leave nepal
where the covert 19 situation is getting
really bad
like neighboring india nepal is reeling
from a deadly second wave of the
coronavirus
the poorest border between the two
countries has contributed to
skyrocketing case numbers
nepal's main towns and cities are in
lockdown
the health ministry says the situation
is unmanageable
doctors and nurses are being pushed to
[Applause]
but the situation is getting complicated
our colleagues are working very hard
they are on duty for 24 hours
we have even been giving oxygen to
patients in chairs
nepal has called for international help
as case numbers hit record highs the
country's neglected healthcare system is
facing collapse
with the lockdown in place many migrant
workers have returned from the cities to
their homes in rural areas while
kathmandu's hospitals struggle to save
lives fear is growing of outbreaks in
the remote regions lacking healthcare
infrastructure
and let's bring in now asmr of the
international federation of the red
cross and the red crescent societies in
nepal he joins us from the capital
kathmandu thank you so much for taking
the time to speak with us uh your
organization is helping there on the
ground what's most urgently needed
yeah yeah uh as your report just said
the situation with the second wave of
covert is
very deadly and alarming and just to
give you some uh quick uh figures
just in the past few weeks the covet
rate has increased by about 50 times
and in march
we were talking about a hundred
infections a day but just in the last
few days we are talking about over 7
000. um
the
death rate is also unprecedented in
nepali standards uh we are talking about
over 50 deaths each day
um this is
also very very alarming
the ifrc works with the red crest cross
volunteers on the ground the red cross
volunteers are very very active in
dealing with preventive measures support
to national and medical services as well
as vaccination efforts
and as you may also be aware that many
of the richer countries we're talking
about a rate of vaccination about 30
percent whereas in nepal is barely one
percent at the moment
is it set to get worse than in india you
think i mean you you've you've been on
the ground there in fact we're gonna see
some footage um you know that you sent
to us in fact of of how you have been
experiencing this firsthand where do you
see the trajectory going right now is it
getting worse is it getting better if
you look at
yeah it's definitely getting
it it's very bad at the moment uh india
has about 48 times the population of
nepal
and if you multiply that by the number
of infections which is over 7 000 a day
and
a death rate of 54.55 a day in the last
few days the figures are very close and
if we do not do anything fast
uh to curb to put the situation under
control uh it could be just
on par with the situation in india
what do you need to get the situation
under control in your view
yeah uh
the three main things uh the red cross
is very active on the preventive
measures uh
in
22 of the 77 districts in nepal and
kathmandu the kathmandu valley where
there's a lot of infections uh
volunteers are dealing with safety
messages hand washing social distancing
supporting quarantine
and promoting vaccination
the second is
that a lot of volunteers are also
helping national and local authorities
with medical
services and you've in your report we're
talking about lack of oxygen in
hospitals and there are also lack of
frontline workers in the hospitals and
you will see in some of the hospitals
people are just lying on the floor
and
finally vaccines and vaccination the red
cross has also been supporting the
public authority the health authorities
in getting vaccinations the arms of
people but right now there is a huge
shortage of vaccines
and this is
an area that we really need to do more
with the international community
and with covet not only in nepal but
around the world i want to stress the
fact that no one is safe unless everyone
is safe
that's a really important message
and one that we thank you for joining us
here on dw news to share we also thank
you for the work that you are doing
there osmar ulla of the international
federation of the red cross and the red
crescent societies in nepal we
appreciate it
thank you